- [Instructor] My three
favorite cities to visit
are Kyoto, Japan; Barcelona,
Spain; and Sydney, Australia.
So, the way it's written right over here
is very strange because
we're talking about
our three favorite cities,
but they're listing,
when they just separated
everything out here with a comma
it makes Japan look
like one of the cities.
And we know that Japan isn't a city.
And it makes Spain look
like one of the cities.
It just lists Kyoto, Japan;
Barcelona, Spain,
but we know that Japan
is just give telling us
what country Kyoto is in
and Spain is just telling us
what country Barcelona is.
And so what we really wanna do
is we wanna separate Kyoto, Japan
from Barcelona, Spain
from Sydney, Australia.
And so typically when you list things
you would use a comma,
except when the things you're listing
have commas in them.
Then you would wanna use semicolons.
So we definitely wanna change this
and ideally, ideally we would put.
Ideally we would put semicolons.
Semicolon here
and then another semicolon
right over there.
Now let's see which choices do that.
So we have, and actually this last,
we already had a semicolon
right over there.
So really just turn this
comma into a semicolon.
So Kyoto, Japan semicolon
Barcelona, Spain semicolon
and Sydney, Australia.
Yep, that looks great.
This one has the same issue.
Kyoto, Japan
Barcelona, Spain
and then they got rid of that semicolon
and they put another comma.
So this one is strange.
Once again it looks like it's listing
more than three cities
or it's counting Japan and Spain as cities
and then it says Kyoto, Japan semicolon.
Barcelona, Spain.
But then they put the comma.
But here, once we start
listing things with semicolons
we just keep listing
things with semicolons.
So this one is not right as well.